[Music]
and a disgusting smelly pillow so far my
stay at Vermont's fake four seasons has
been a huge disappointment the owner
doesn't know his ass from his elbow I
have a knife the staff don't get paid
the guests are miserable only later the
dog is happy here I'm hoping a quick dip
in the swimming pool will get my day off
to a better start does that look like a
present from Layla a floating turd layer
reduced you to the pool there's no way
I'm going in there how about the hot tub
[Music]
Leila hasn't taken a [ __ ] in at great
news
[Music]
why
[Music]
gorgeous you
this place has a lot of potential but
don't even get sandy to stop hiding from
his guests and the problems here I'm
gonna confront him with his worst
nightmare to wake him up to his
responsibilities as an innkeeper Winant
going yes oh sure
well come upstairs I'm gonna show you
yeah
I'm thinking okay he's gonna show me
something wrong maybe the hole in the
wall bored by the door
[Music]
good morning no there's no room full of
people thought I was gonna pass out
I'm here to help this place I really
need your honest feedback sir would you
mind if we stop here it was a a sign
that I liked when we came in about all
dogs has to be on your leash and we had
our dog and we come in and was
immediately another dog coming out it's
not on a leash the dogs friendly but he
always takes a few minutes with new
animals sure I had Reds and it was dog
friendly I thought it was really
interesting that there was a dog laying
in the dining room and as much as we
like dogs I don't want a dog in where
I'm eating I agree I think I was
disgusting there's one last person I'd
like to introduce you to Amy Loomis
this lady is the general manager of one
of the Hilton brand hotels and if
there's one thing this lady knows is how
to run a hotel first impressions walking
in at dinner there was dog hair on the
tablecloth dog hair on the plate that we
were given they asked to speak with the
manager I was told there is no manager
we have an owner I said I'd like to
speak with them then I was told you were
too busy I've never had the complaints
that I had today it's humiliating it's
embarrassing it's like being flogged in
the center of town there's something I
need to show you all I need you all to
put a pair of these on please
okay you gonna for me car Oh hot and
absorbing everything yeah
yes okay
like soft now this black light shows up
bodily fluids y ou C register sound EQ
say that yes yeah I slept on that pillow
charging guests to sleep on such filth
is outrageous the quilt see the slashes
yeah that is begins with s yeah I'm
sorry yeah
disgusting but I want to show you
something over by your feet sandy come
over here do you see that oh yeah
the carpet sandy yes I mean honestly
madam your feet are right on it stands
on the carpet er I have no idea that
could be a dog that could be a human if
it's a human good Christmas just when
you thought it was safe to walk in bare
feet trust me that has never ever been
clean absolutely disgusting oh yes
please take your glasses off chef we
have another day to stay here today and
tomorrow and after seeing the light I
don't want to stay here tonight I don't
want to put my head on that pillow over
any of the other pillows
[Music]
no one will return an existing guess
that we have want to check out thank you
madam please if you're looking at a
roomful of customers who are looking at
you saying I can't believe you put me in
there and that's maddening and it's
embarrassing I need some fresh I feel
sick it sucks to know where I am right
right now it's horrifying it does hurt
me inside the tears just keep coming out
of my face
it's not what I wanted
I'm mortified